some people ask what is the right age to
learn your why there's no right age to
learn your wife your wives fully formed
by the time you're about eighteen
nineteen twenty fully formed and so
anytime after that you can find it out
for the whole four your whole life and
the longer life you've lived you just
have more data points you have more
information to look at to find patterns
and so people want to know if they can
help their teenagers find their wide
answers of course you can especially for
somebody who's a little younger whether
Y is still forming I mean the odds are
and again I don't I don't know the
science I just know from from from
talking to people in from experience but
maybe the Y form is a little younger is
fully formed a little younger so
absolutely you can talk to your kids and
find out what drives them and when
they've been happy and most importantly
is actually pay attention to when your
kids are inspired and when they're happy
and encourage that behavior encourage
them to do more of that because the
clearer they are of their why and the
things that drive them and have support
they will build confidence for those
things in their life and that will
actually set them on a very very good
path going forwards most of us
unfortunately are not given that
opportunity
we're often just told to get a job or do
well at school or study harder and then
by the time we're 30 or 40 or 50 years
old we wake up and realize that we've
worked hard we've gotten good grades
we've got a job and yet we don't know
who we are or what drives us so really a
great parent what they do will help push
a child push someone in a student if
you're a mentor a teacher to someone in
the direction that naturally drives them
early and that Y will become loud and
clear to them at a much much earlier age